South Korea is facing a population
crisis the country's birth rate is now
the lowest on Earth with big
consequences for everything from the
workforce to pensions oh look at that
baby I can't focus looking at this baby
the number of people living there is
projected to shrink by more than a
quarter by 2070. Elizabeth Palmer
traveled to the capital Seoul and met
with families who are struggling with
the high costs of having children
South Korea's most precious resource is
dwindling for every hundred Korean women
fewer than 80 babies are being born
marketing manager tune on has decided to
Buck that Trend she's expecting a
brother for three-year-old
ayum Lim in just a few weeks how
difficult was it to decide to have
another one oh very hard
it was only possible because there's
daycare right in her office building a
perk of working for the giant
conglomerate CJ Foods they also offer
extra paid leaves for the pregnant
workers so they can go to go and see the
doctors on a regular basis and is that
unusual in Korea I think so yeah it's
only for like a big major companies I
think they do offer these benefits most
Koreans aren't that lucky on average
they work some of the longest hours in
the industrialized world and it's women
who usually do the cooking and cleaning
so a child piles on even more stress on
the weekends Central Seoul skating rink
offers fresh air and freedom from the
grind of that hyper competitive Society
do you hope to have a family one day
Yoon young her and sukjun Lee are soon
to be married but they aren't sure they
can afford a baby
there is such a lot of pressure to get
ahead you told me so private education
is not an option it's a must
Korea is the most expensive country in
the world to raise a child partly
because success depends on getting top
grades at the very best schools
for the Lees who welcome little C June
to the world four months ago crashing
school fees are still some way off but
Mom soman says the bills started to pile
up the minute she got pregnant
hospitals the hospital and doctors
Korea's government has spent 200 billion
dollars to boost the birth rate
including a monthly subsidy to help with
baby expenses those of course are just
the beginning good school good
University
eventually a good partner or wife it
starts here and goes for
decades
and before he gets to elementary school
soman says I'd like him to learn Basics
like maybe martial arts or swimming
these tiny creatures turn into such
giant commitments the country may want
more of them but more and more young
people are deciding however adorable
they can do without
for CBS mornings Elizabeth Palmer Seoul
South Korea
yeah I mean you have four I have four in
two countries and I'm 25 years old and I
look like this I have four kids will do
a lot to you but look uh she's talking
about South Korea but you know there are
a lot of families here also looking at
the cost of college the cost of housing
the cost of medical and thinking I'm
only gonna have one or no kids at all
daycare is unbelievably expensive and
then you think about countries like
China they ended their one child policy
in 2016 to try to boost birth rates and
people didn't take them up on that offer
because it is so expensive to have
children and now in China I think in
2021 they are allowed families to have
three kids which is huge another word
for children is taxpayer there it is